[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition de votre journal
d'actualités locales voici les titres de
ce mardi 15 mai 2018 la police nationale
entend recruter huit mille agents dont
trois minutes 3 son écart tient de la
dre voilà les images une campagne
nationale de communication vient d'être
lancé et parmi elles les acteurs des
policiers yvelinois vous découvrirez les
squats et puis les témoignages dans un
instant le 18 mai journée européenne de
lutte contre l'obésité en france six
millions et demi de personnes sont
considérés comme obèses
nous en parlerons avec la présidente de
l'association les poids plumes claude
hill canal claudine canal et puis notre
portrait de la semaine comme chaque
mardi aujourd'hui rencontre avec éric
charland fondateur du club des petits
lots de plaisir l'homme qui des
disciplines qui regroupe de nombreux
arts martiaux la première phase de la
nouvelle procédure parcours sub pour
l'inscription dans le supérieur pour les
élèves s'est achevée le 31 mars les
lycéens apprentis étudiants en
réorientation et candidats inscrits à
l'étranger ou non scolarisés ont enfin
confirmé leurs voeux ils sont 70 1913
avoir fait la démarche dans l'académie
de versailles chacun pouvant faire
plusieurs veut plus de 243 milles se
sont portés vers des licences à
l'université et près de 470 milles vers
des filières dite sélective classe
préparatoire ou encore école
d'ingénieurs à noter que l'académie de
versailles annonce la création est de
1500 places supplémentaires afin de
répondre au mieux aux demandes
d'orientation de chacun c'est une
première depuis 18 ans vous l'avez
peut-être déjà vu sur votre écran ce la
police nationale lance une opération
séduction via des spots publicitaires à
l'objectif donné l envie aux plus jeunes
de s'engager et des vidéos sont aussi
est disponible sur les réseaux sociaux
plusieurs et les noirs ont participé
activement à cette campagne de
communication le reportage de nicolas
kirillovitch
protéger chacun de vous au quotidien est
le sens de notre engagement
plusieurs ambiances et plusieurs
interventions policières en l'espace de
30 secondes seulement le tout valorisé
avec des images soignées la nouvelle
campagne de communication de la police
nationale se veut juste et efficace pour
tenter de convaincre les plus jeunes de
devenir policier toutes les facettes du
métier sont mises en avant il y à la
police judiciaire l'investigation la
police secours la police du quotidien
mais aussi des métiers de geek comme la
cybercriminalité motocyclistes de la
police crs en milieu montagnard c'est
vraiment le mille métiers qui s'offrent
aux jeunes alors oui on a voulu montrer
cette diversité
mais le point commun entre tous ces
métiers c'est l'objectif ultime
préserver la paix publique protéger les
gens pour ce premier spot diffusé à la
télévision depuis 18 ans une vingtaine
d'agents joue les comédiens parmi eux
plusieurs yvelinois durant trois jours
de tournage ils ont ainsi pu découvrir
un nouvel univers
c'est une belle expérience quoi j'avais
jamais vu en tournage en vrai donc non
c'était ces tests est cool mais les deux
premiers jours je peux vous assurer que
je suis rentré chez moi j'avais très
froid quoi au début au début du tournage
c'était une station c'était clairement
cyan ce que toutes les deux secondes ce
qui est trois secondes
coupez tournée écouter tournée et c'est
vrai qu'on n'est pas habitué ces essais
mais après quand on voit le résultat
final sera prêt on est on est vraiment
content vraiment satisfaite en plus de
la télévision différents clips sont
également diffusés sur les réseaux
sociaux
selon un sondage réalisé pour cette
campagne près de 31 % des jeunes ont
déjà pensé à entrer dans la police 8000
postes sont à pourvoir cette année 18
mai journée européenne de l'obésité est
une maladie qui touche un nombre
grandissant de personnes 16 % de la
population française au niveau mondial
le surpoids concerne plus d'un milliard
et demi d plus de 20 ans un chiffre qui
pourrait doubler encore d'ici à 2030 une
véritable épidémie claudine canal
bonsoir fou soit on va tout de suite
corrigé avec vous je vais vous présenter
vous êtes présidente de l'association
poids plume vous êtes mobilisés on va
parler de vos actions et on va tout de
suite corrigé des chiffres que j'ai
donné
disiez tout à l'heure c'est passé
million et demi de personnes en france
c'est plus encore on est accru de 7
millions actuellement donc on peut
parler de véritable épidémie une
progression très très très rapide très
rapide
et en plus ce qui est affolant c'est que
qu on avancer et puis les les couches
enfants sont touchés
donc c'est alarmant comment on peut
expliquer cette progression aussi rapide
alors qu'on a l'impression aussi que les
campagnes de communication pour alerter
aussi pour faire attention à ce qu'on
mange à la santé aux sports sont plus en
plus nombreuses c'est beaucoup plus
c'est beaucoup plus je veux dire
beaucoup plus multifactorielle la
population effectivement pense que c'est
un état de fait mais c'est une maladie
déjà bon la maladie a été reconnue en
1997 par l' oms l'organisation de
mondiale de la santé donc c'est une très
jeune malade il reconnu elle n'est pas
pris en charge en termes de longue durée
donc ça aussi les gens comprennent pas
que c'est une maladie et toutes les
personnes pensent que en fait
et si on est obèse c'est parce qu'on
nous laisse aller le plus important pour
aussi votre association c'est aussi de
lutter contre ces idées reçues elle
expliquait que voilà si on est obèse
c'est pas parce qu'on se laisse aller
voilà pour faire simple c'est le regard
des autres le plus difficile donc
l'objectif de notre association
effectivement à la 4 axes et
l'information le conseil
l'accompagnement au quotidien ça c'est
très important et la construction des
parcours de soins avec les équipes
médicales et paramédicales parce qu'on
amène effectivement une autre expérience
de vécu et ce qui fait enrichir et donne
une valeur ajoutée un parcours de soins
vous même vous avez été touchés par la
maladie et vous avez déploré le manque
d' écoute aussi à l'époque plus jeunes
peut-être aussi et le manque de conseils
alors c'est pour ça qu effectivement je
me suis engagé je me suis engagé depuis
à peu près sept ans maintenant à fond
pour aider les personnes plus jeunes à
prendre conscience qu'ils sont malades
et qu'il faut se prendre en charge
avec cette association poids plume
comment vous intervenez justement vous
et puis peut-être quelles sont les
demandes aussi qu'ils sont exprimés que
ce soit par les plus jeunes ou par les
autres
qu est ce qui ressort le plus souvent
alors ils ont vraiment besoin d'une
écoute d'aucun jugement pas de tabou
donc nous on forme nous tous nos
bénévoles à y être bienveillant avec
toutes les personnes à avoir de
l'empathie aussi parce que et pas avoir
de rejet et les personnes au fait ils
apprécient de s'orienter
il s'oriente vers nous pour et pour pour
avoir ce soutien ou au quotidien on
parle de ce travail d'accompagnement se
caractérise comment concrètement ne
serait ce que pendant la la journée du
18 ça se prolonge au-delà de la journée
du 18 mai d'ailleurs tout à fait cédé
hier déjà déjà dès hier à poissy saint
germain ne pas très loin de chez vous et
comment on accompagne les patients et
ben on craie des créneaux de marche
on les aide à se remettre en activité
physique ont créé des lieux d'écouté
avec des permanences
ici sur ce territoire par exemple un
attrape à l'hôpital de trappes en
partenariat avec cet hôpital et on crée
effectivement un lieu d'écouté tous les
deuxièmes samedis de chaque mois pour
pour venir échanger et effectivement
pour orienter le mieux possible
toutes les personnes qui sont touchées
par cette maladie a à prendre la bonne
décision et se prendre en charge
on va renvoyer tout de suite vers la
page facebook également de l'association
pourra voir aussi les dates des
prochains événements qui sont programmés
également sur paris oui précédente où
céline mais pas seulement voilà ces sud
yvelines c'est paris c'est la page
facebook c'est les poids plumes france
et toutes les actions c'est une journée
nationale qui est portée par le
collectif national des associations
d'obèses qui a reçu le patronage du
bruxelles en fait du clr la 9e édition
cette année et tout les toutes les
actions sont retrouvés surgi au tir à
sanaa au point fr on parle même de
journée de mobilisation européenne
peut-être on peut faire un point sur sur
la proche aussi de l'obésité de la
maladie de chez nos voisins européens
est ce que tous les pays évoluent de la
même manière non pas du tout
la prise en charge de l'obésité
qui est la mieux acceptée en terme de
maladies c'est au portugal en italie on
parle pas de chirurgie c'est quelque
chose de tabou puisque bon effectivement
pour pallier cette maladie il ya
différentes possibilités à notre
association nous accompagnent
effectivement les personnes qui veulent
un parcours de chirurgie mais pas
seulement des personnes qui sont en
surpoids
puisqu'on ne peut pas laisser devant la
porte les personnes qui ont des
problèmes et qui sont malheureux quoi la
solution aujourd'hui c'est uniquement la
chirurgie non pas du tout il ya des
centres spécialisés d'ailleurs il ya des
centres spécialisés qui peuvent prendre
en long séjour en long séjour pour faire
des rééquilibrage alimentaire
c'est un programme multi disciplines
donc on a le droit à avoir quand on
rentre dans ce programme des notions de
diététique des notions psychologique on
est suivi par un psychologue
on peut travailler sur des ateliers
parce que c'est pareil les idées reçues
que l'on a
par rapport à la maladie l'entourage
n'est pas un super compagnon de la
personne obèse on a aussi de l'activité
donc je j'ai dû le dire déjà activité
physique qui est mis en place un certain
nombre de choses aussi bien la re
découverte de son corps l'accès
par des gestes en socio esthétique et
puis on a aussi tout les toutes les les
actions médicales qui sont pas
répertoriés vraiment comme médicales
comme la sophrologie des études de
pleine conscience des prises de
conscience voulais vous parler de
psychologie ans quand vous parlez de
maladies on parle de maladie psychique
ah non mais toute façon la problématique
de la personne obèse ça passe par la
psychologie il faut vraiment un
accompagnement psychologique pour
comprendre d'où vient le mal est et
c'est une c'est un travail d'équipé et
réactions bien souvent à un événement
derrière ça peut pas ça peut et ne pas
que et ça ça peut être aussi un problème
génétique c'est multifactoriel et c'est
très compliqué c'est pas une maladie
simple ou et associés plein d'autres
maladies plein d'autres pathologies
comme le diabète l'hypertension et le
cne du sommeil explique aujourd'hui
concrètement pour endiguer un peu
l'épidémie pour endiguer l'épidémie déjà
de faire passer les messages qu'il faut
dépister au plus vite la maladie que qu'
il faut orienter des patients à se
prendre en charge et arrêtez de juger
tout toutes les personnes qui souffrent
de cette maladie
merci beaucoup d'être venu remplacer
pour nous parler du travail de votre
association
elle et poids plume et on voit vers la
page facebook un pour avoir tout le
détail des des rendez-vous qui sont
proposés merci à vous cette édition du 7
8 le journal du 15 mai et se poursuit
avec un petit retour en arrière nous
revenons à présent sur le 27e mais
dessert c'est à maurepas regarder les
filles
je vous présente mes à léa c'est une
petite brebis doux et sans elle est née
le 3 mars 2018 avec les cochons dans ce
sont les stars de la ferme pédagogique
de cette 27e édition du mai dessert
éleveuse à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
hélène guillaume est venu présenter ses
différents animaux j'essaye de les
sensibiliser aux animaux de la ferme
leur expliquer leurs habitudes leurs
comportements comment ils vivent ce
qu'il mange comment les aborder comme on
les respecte et bages et caresser les
animaux de la mort et c'était des pod
illizi de des optiques au chaud ils sont
tous louent et la vie sont très gentils
à côté des animaux de la ferme des
fleurs des plantes aromatiques et des
légumes toute la biodiversité regnault
serre municipale de maurepas durant tout
le week end
le but c'est de faire connaître aux
visiteurs toutes les méthodes qu'on peut
avoir pour jardiner entre autres
d'utiliser des paillages pour preuve
faire de traitement parce que sûrement
pas on est au zéro phytosanitaire
plusieurs milliers de personnes ont
foulé les allées fleuries du mais
dessert le rendez vous est pris au
printemps 2010 9 pour de nouvelles
aventures potagères et animalière voyage
au pays des rêves à présent le pays de
l'inconscient pour nous accompagner dans
ce voyage rien n'allait bonsoir
ses concepteurs metteur en scène de
collecte de rêve c'est un rendez vous
qui se déroula à guyancourt salle des
expositions on va peut-être déjà vous
laisser définir ce qu'est ce rendez-vous
cette création artistique autour du rêve
c'est très simple le titre collecte de
rêve dit bien l'objet de ce projet
[Musique]
dans mon travail je me suis toujours
posé la question
comme j'ai eu la chance de beaucoup
voyager je me suis toujours posé la
question qu'est-ce qui peut relier
toutes les personnes quel que soit leur
âge leur nationalité leur culture leur
langue
j'ai trouvé des endroits comme ça des
terrains communs il ya un terrain que je
trouve particulièrement intéressant
parce que il a à la fois très intime et
en même temps c'est quelque chose qui
est qui a toujours marqué toutes les
sociétés où toutes les civilisations
s'en sont emparés ils ont cherché des
signes des prophéties des dialogues avec
les idiots hong la psychanalyse c'est le
rêve bien sûr c'est le rêve est depuis
cinq ans maintenant une sauveteurs qui
est là la compagnie que je dirige man un
travail dans différents territoires dans
un collectage de rêve
c'est très simple c'est très simple
c'est ce qui s'est passé à guyancourt
vous avez demandé aux habitants de
participer justement et je veux venir
raconter ce qui est présenti l'horaire
ils se sont prêtés assez facilement au
jeu
oui parce que les règles sont claires
c'est à dire que ça se base sur le choix
que vont faire les gens on leur propose
de nous raconter un rêve un cauchemar
peu importe qui peut remonter à
plusieurs dizaines d'années qui peut
remonter à la nuit dernière et les gens
le raconte absolument comme ils veulent
c'est à dire que c'est ça qui est
intéressant je trouve dans ce projet
c'est que 1
tous les rêves qui sont données vont
être restitués
tous vont faire partie de l'oeuvre donc
il ya pas de bons et de mauvais en fait
et la seconde chose qui est très
importante de mon but c'est qu'ils ne
sont pas retouchées
c'est à dire que quel que soit le
langage que vous allez utiliser si vous
me racontez par exemple votre rêve en
quatre mots dans l'oeuvre qu'on va
produire vos quatre mots y seront
il y en aura pas cinq ans n'aura pas 3 a
pris au pied de la lettre on reprend
exactement ce que nous ont donné les
gens maintenant on crée un cadre
brickell effectivement ça va être à
l'heure des musiques malgré tout pour
accompagner abbès et une est une
création lumière installations c'est une
installation sonore et lumineuse et vous
n'avez pas peur de trahir les rêves et
y apporter votre interprétation aussi
parce que lorsque vous choisissez les
musiques
lorsque vous choisissez les lumières ont
il faut de plus imaginez un pont nous
notre travail c'est de créer des ponts
c'est à dire que quand il ya le raja
ultime de la personne qu'on partage
finalement assez peu dans la vie de tous
les jours vous n'allez pas voir votre
boulangère j'en sais rien ailleurs mais
moi je vais pas voir ma boulangère
pouvoir aider mes rêves et nous notre
travail c'est très très simple en fait
c'est de créer des ponts des passerelles
ou ce qu'on rêve et qui des fois n'est
pas facile non plus on a moins on en est
à 580 rêve maintenant on a fait ça à la
réunion à fleury-mérogis avec des
détenus on a fait ça avec des petits
gamins de cp on a fait ça sans toi on a
fait ça vraiment dans des endroits très
différents et ce que je trouve génial
c'est quand tout d'un coup les gens
s'aperçoivent que les rêves qui font
aussi tordu soit il en fait c'est de la
matière communes et les gens se disent
ils sortent et il se dit ah bon alors ça
va je suis pas tout seul est combien un
écho justement d'un rêve à l'autre est
ce qu'un des points communs il ya des
choses dépression millions d enfants et
la diffusion très surprenante mais il
m'est arrivé une fois plus d'une fois
même où le rêve j'avais une jeune fille
de 12 13 ans à peu près qui me raconte
kim a raconté un rêve qui se passait
dans une forêt sous la neige où il y
avait quelqu'un qui la poursuivent et et
le rêve s'est arrêté à l'instant où la
personne ne mettait la main sur l'épaule
et huit mois après je vais dans un autre
endroit je crois que c'était à la
réunion si je me souviens bien
et le rêve commence c'est un homme qui
me dit mon rêve commence je mets la main
sur l'épaule d'une jeune fille dans une
forêt sur la neige et quand on a
quelqu'un qui vous dit ça on se dit ah
peut-être que il ya quelque chose qui
nous relient les uns aux autres il n'y a
pas besoin d'être mystique pour ça il
suffit juste d'écouter peut-être quelque
chose qui nous relient les uns aux
autres et qui nous soulage aussi encore
une femme moi je fais ce projet là parce
que je sentais que ça allait créer un
soulagement ça crée de la communauté en
fait et vous voyez toutes les dieux
c'est qu'on en a des séparations dans
notre société
dans notre monde l'âge ne serait-ce que
les enfants par rapport aux adultes
après bien sûr on a la culture le socio
professionnelles le compte en banque
tout ce que vous voulez tout ça un par
un tous y saute tous ces verrous il
saute et on se retrouve avec quoi une
espèce d'essence en fait des gens et de
l'humanité et donc c'est pour ça que
l'humanité voyez avec un grand h
il n'y a pas besoin d'en faire un truc
très lointain c'est là c'est juste
maintenant il faut des ponts pour rien
pour y accéder et pour découvrir une
partie de votre travail c'est à
guyancourt à partir de demain le montage
de l'exposition s'est terminée
aujourd'hui juste une dernière question
est ce qu'il ya des dérives que vous
refusez vous sélectionnez n'aurait
jamais jamais c'est un principe c'est un
principe c'est à dire qu' on ne peut pas
d'un côté accueillir et de l'autre côté
sélectionné pour moi c'est deux choses
qui sont complètement contradictoire et
puis encore une fois je pense que on vit
dans un monde qui est basée sur la
sélection qui est basé toute la
civilisation est basé là dessus et je
pense que les gens de façon plus ou
moins
consciente on va dire on cherche tous
des endroits dans lesquels tous ces
trucs là il tombe et donc le fait de
dire à quelqu'un
quoi que vous me disiez je l'accepterais
et ce sera entendu eh ben ça soulage et
étrangement j'ai jamais eu de rêve je me
suis dit mon dieu ça se doit tenir ma
promesse donc je vais le faire entendre
mais c'est non il ya quelque chose qui
est pris en charge collectivement même
si des fois les rêves sont très violents
mais c'est pas grave
collecte de rêve à découvrir à partir de
demain jusqu'au 30 mai à guyancourt pour
découvrir une partie de votre travail
justement autour du du rêve le travail
de yan allegret merci encore à vous
aussi en collaboration avec le service
action culturelle de la commune donc de
guyancourt merci à vous la suite de ce
journal c'est avec un portrait comme
chaque mardi nous allons parler de
l'homme qui dos est un art martial qui
comprend du karaté du mma ou encore du
krav maga un mélange de différentes
disciplines et nous sommes allés
rencontrer l'un de ses fondateurs et
c'était il ya une trentaine d'années il
enseigna plaisir
portrait de la semaine
pour se défendre en cas d'attaqué ou
pour s'entretenir les arts martiaux sont
des disciplines privilégiée dans ses
cours éric charland enseigne plusieurs
techniques de combat réunis en un seul
et même art martial le camp multi d'eau
c'est un art martial de synthèse qui
fait la synthèse donc des arts martiaux
d'orient et des sports de combat de
d'occident on a évidemment tous les arts
martiaux japonais aussi jujitsu gtug
wrapping donc là c'est une forme propre
à l'école on à la pratique des armes les
scream à tout ce qui vient donc plutôt
des philippines que des arts malaisien
en compte le kobudo d'okinawa y un mais
aussi tout ça donc toujours formulé avec
des principes communs qui permet de
passer d'un art martial un autre sans
avoir besoin de juxtaposer les les
techniques un tour du monde des arts
martiaux qui passe aussi par la russie
avec le sistema du mma ou le krav maga
il règne eric a créé l'homme qui dort il
y a trente ans
[Musique]
tous les jours je pratique entre 3h et
4h pour faire mes propres recherches et
c'est vrai que la force de pratique et
de recherche etc
j'ai pu déjà haut niveau c'est le
défense pur éliminer des techniques qui
ne fonctionnait pas j'ai beaucoup
pratiqué les principes sol les principes
communs aux arts martiaux niveau de la
biomécanique et des principaux signes
vers celles comme la stabilité le
l'équilibré la globalité du corps le
relâchement musculaire la respiration
aujourd'hui son académie et présenta
plaisir d'autres clubs existent à poissy
mais aussi au canada et au congo 450
adhérents pratiquent ces disciplines
passionné d'arts martiaux depuis l'âge
de 5 ans le plaisir wwa est aussi tombé
amoureux de cette philosophie qui prône
l'épanouissement personnel et le
bien-être
ce soir-là cours de tai chi qui débute
toujours par un moment de méditation
[Musique]
pour se recontacter mot niveau de son
intériorité sert d'être plus en lien
avec soit lâché peut-être un peu plus
sur les sur tout ce qui peut nous gêner
c'est
les schémas du passé les lycées la rive
du passé donc on va réellement apprendre
à apprendre un petit peu de distance à
changer de rapport aux événements que
l'on vit pour vivre plus dans l'instant
dans le présent cheminée pour se
réaliser et puis me sentir bien en
général je dire dans la même idée il a
également créé l'ostéo qu'énergie ainsi
que différents programmes de remise en
forme comme le calice techniques
fonctionnelles movement autant de
méthodes accessible au plus grand nombre
eric souhaite transmettre ses
compétences et accompagner ses élèves
dans leur évolution
c'est vrai que ça donne une position de
force intérieure quelque part face aux
événements de la vie sire que même si on
a des du stress des peurs des émotions
et cetera bon c'est vrai qu'on va comme
gérer les choses à apprendre à gérer
notre dans l'accueil et puis en général
on va on va toujours travaillé pour
évoluer pour continuer d'avancer dans
les objectifs que l'on s'est fixés dans
notre propre ville
un enseignement physique et spirituelle
des stages de kido ou de jahia yoga sont
organisées régulièrement pour découvrir
ou se perfectionner
deuxième rendez vous à présent avec
grégory canal et depuis elle la
croisette il a fait le déplacement lors
du festival de cannes à la rencontre des
eyzies blinois présents sur place cette
fois-ci en rencontre avec un producteur
qui recherchent des financements
le festival de cannes c'est le rendez
vous des hautes sphères du cinéma c'est
aussi pour un jeune réalisateur un lieu
idéal pour se développer
originaire de plaisir quentin dupieux en
est à son cinquième festival à la tête
d'une société de production et multiplie
à cannes les rendez vous d'affaires
objectif financer ses projets
audiovisuels qui se chiffrent pour
certains à plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'euros
[Musique]
quentin depuis la dernière fois qu'on
vous avez suivi a quitté il ya deux ans
vous présentiez ici un court métrage au
chante film corner qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pour vous depuis ses deux ans et
bat depuis ses deux ans j'ai monté ma
société de production
velvet sonne production on s'occupe
principalement à deux axes principaux de
travail une partie publicité à la fois
sur la france et l'international
notamment avec la chine et une partie
production de longs métrages
là aussi avec une portée internationale
et multiculturelle
quand on a une société de production
forcément au début d'un projet
audiovisuel il ya une question qui
revient c'est le financement comment ça
se passe quand on veut monter un projet
et bien quand on veut monter un projet
de
de production de longs métrages en plus
clair c'est déjà beaucoup de poids
beaucoup de patience et beaucoup de
rencontres de réseaux nous nous on a
même des projets donc c'est toujours le
jeu c'est de convaincre des
investisseurs de venir investir dans ce
conte dans l'est dans les films qu'on a
envie de développer de produire donc
tout le jeu de la production et là c'est
à dire d'aller voir le maximum de gens
de trouver des financements dans le plus
de pays possible suivant les productions
qu'on veut faire sur les pays qu'on veut
toucher les marchés quand vous touchez
et d'aller chercher des investisseurs
des financiers des gens qui croient dans
le projet pour les emmener avec nous
dans cette aventure pour pour créer tout
ça quand vous serez à cannes jusqu'à la
quasi fin du festival jusqu'au 18 mai à
quoi ressemblent vos journées
concrètement depuis le début de ce
festival bien concrètement c'est
beaucoup de rendez-vous a principalement
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de rendez vous
avec voilà qu'on a préparé en amont des
gens qu'on rencontre aussi des soirées
et fameuse soirée cannoise où il ya
beaucoup de travail derrière qing et de
rencontres aussi et qui nous permet
voilà chaque jour d'avoir un platini
s'est établie entre les rendez-vous les
déjeuners et les dîners et d'enchaîner
tout ça vous allez pas nous dire qu'ils
voulaient rencontrer mais ce que des
personnes sont intéressées par les
projets que vous présentez on a beaucoup
de chance cette année c'est un fait
celle qui se passe très bien pour nous
on a de l'intérêt notamment du côté de
la chine on a de l'intérêt aussi du côté
de l'angleterre et des états unis avec
des projets qu'on a notamment un projet
entre l'angleterre et la france donc ça
se passe plutôt très bien on est très
content avec mon associé au festival ces
rendez vous avec les potentiels
financiarisé roule ici au sein du palais
du festival n'ont finalement très très
peu c'est plutôt dans les restaurants
dans les hôtels dans les bars
le palais c'est beaucoup pour la vente
des films ont souvent des semis sont
déjà faits nous on est quand même à une
tape de financement on est moins formel
je vais dans les rendez-vous les lieux
dans lesquels on se rend compte avec
avec les investisseurs et les autres les
coproducteurs chaud c'est votre
cinquième festival
il faut être ici à cannes surtout quand
on est à la tête d'une société de
production il faut il faut être présent
ici à tienne effectivement en tant que
ces deux productions c'est vraiment
important pour nous d'être présents à
cannes c'est le seul moment de l'année
tous les pays du monde sont présents
même lieu au même endroit avec la même
passion du cinéma et pour développer des
projets justement là-dessus donc c'est
très très important pour nous et c'est
une plate forme incroyable
chaque année merci content du puits
merci beaucoup merci grégory
focus à présent sur un film
subventionnées par la région ile de
france celui ci fait partie de la
sélection de la quinzaine des
réalisateurs festival parallèle
amine de philippe faucon c'est
l'histoire d'un sénégalais venus
travailler en france il a laissé
derrière lui son épouse et ses enfants
sa vie solitaire va basculer le jour où
il rencontre et gabriel avec qui une
relation se noue amine fait une pause
alors ça y est vous allez terminer ce
soir
cent soixante dix huit touche à sa fin
demain la suite de nos rencontres avec
les yvelinois de la croisette
c'est la fin de ce journal rendez vous
demain à partir de 18h en direct avec
nicolas kirillovitch pour une nouvelle
édition
[Musique]